“Every time a bell rings, an angel gets its
wings.” It’s an iconic line from “It’s a Wonderful
Life” and even if you don’t believe in angels,
it’s a pleasant image. After all, angels are
the embodiment of goodness and light, so an angel
getting its wings has to be a good thing, right?
Well, as anyone who’s ever eaten one
too many Christmas cookies can tell you,
it’s possible to have too much of a good
thing. Even something that sounds like
the embodiment of all things good, in theory,
can become deadly when taken to the extreme.
That is where SCP-469, also known
as the Many-Winged Angel, comes in.
This angel-like creature is anything
but innocent and in fact it has been
responsible for multiple deaths of SCP
Foundation personnel during its captivity.
SCP-469 may be deadly, but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious,
ethereal way. When first seen,
it appears to be nothing more
than a massive pile of pristine white
feathers, like something out of a pillow
commercial. The pile measures 24 feet in
diameter and weighs at least two tons.
However, like many of the entities
contained within the walls of the
Foundation’s countless containment
sites, all is not as it seems with 469.
What looks at first glance to be a
pile of feathers is in fact a dense,
curled mass of giant wings. The wings
vary in size, from the tiny wingspan of
a sparrow to the staggering 3.6-meter
wingspan of the wandering albatross.
The one thing they have in
common is their plumage,
with each wing being covered with
the same glossy white feathers.
The Foundation was able to perform a series of
X-rays on the mass of wings, revealing a skeletal
structure beneath the feathers. Like those of
a bird, the wings’ bones are hollow. However,
they are unnaturally soft and flexible, allowing
for a range of motion that no known birds possess.
This accounts for the curvature of the wings, and
their ability to coil tightly into each other.
The X-Ray also provided the first, and only
recorded glimpse at the creature hiding underneath
all of the feathers. At the center of the layers
upon layers of wings, is a humanoid creature,
curled into a fetal position. In
defiance of the laws of natural anatomy,
every single wing appears to be fused to
this creature’s spine. How it would be able
to move under the weight of these wings,
or if it even could, is as of yet unknown.
The first Foundation personnel lost to SCP-469
were D-class personnel, D-112 and D-624,
who were sent in to investigate
the nature of the creature and
attempt to contact the humanoid
entity identified on the X-rays.
112 and 624 entered the room, equipped with gloves
and protective eye gear, as scientists watched the
situation unfold on a monitor on a video feed. No
one expected much to come of the encounter, the
working hypothesis was that the layers of feathers
would simply be too thick to get through without
seriously damaging the bones. It would be a
fairly uneventful experiment, or so they thought.
112 approached SCP-469 first,
and attempted to part a section of its feathers
with his hands as 624 stood back and observed.
The moment his fingertips touched the
feathers, a rustling sound filled the
room. The feathers began to quiver, shaking as
if all waking up at once from a deep slumber.
Suddenly, in the blink of an eye, the hundreds
and hundreds of wings unfurled and pulled 112
into their depths. He was swept into a
swirl of feathers and, within seconds,
he had disappeared from view completely.
Though 624 and the scientists watching on
their monitor could no longer see him…they
could certainly hear him. From the moment the
wings pulled him into the sea of feathers,
112 had begun to scream in
agony. His screams persisted,
growing louder and more desperate even
as his voice cracked and grew weak.
624 stood, frozen in place with fear and shock.
624 was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112 from
the feathers, but made no move to do so. He simply
stared at the feathers, eyes wide, face pale,
as the pained shrieks of his colleague bounced off
the sterile white walls of the containment room.
A guard called over the intercom, threatening
to terminate 624 if he did not attempt to remove
112 from SCP-469’s grasp. This warning
seemed to shock 624 back into action,
and he made a run for the center feathers,
arms up to protect his face. Again, the sound
of rustling as the feathers began to quake. The
wings unfurled once more, and 624 did not even
have a chance to turn back before he was pulled in
to meet the same dismal fate as the other D Class.
His screams of pain joined 112’s
as the scientists watching over
the monitor could do nothing to help them.
As the two men cried out in pain and
horror from within their winged prison,
something began to happen that the
scientists had never seen before.
The feathers started to shake again, faster than
before, and at first the wings appeared to be
unfolding again. Upon a second look though, it
was clear they hadn’t moved. There were simply
more of them now. As the men continued
to scream, more feathers appeared,
the wings stretching out and elongating,
and new wings sprouting as if from nowhere.
SCP-469 appeared to be feeding
on the sound of the screams,
and using that energy to expand. It was only
after several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the wings
did too. At this point, the wings shifted again,
expelling the bodies of 112 and 624 from within
its folds, dropping them limply on the ground.
Though their deaths were unfortunate, the loss of
112 and 624 did reveal some new information about
SCP-469. First, that it could grow, and apparently
needed to feed on sounds in order to do so.
Second, that it was deadly to humans,
and most likely to other living things
as well. Autopsies of 112 and
624’s corpses would later reveal
exactly what happened to them,
and how SCP-469 kills its prey.
Though 469’s feathers may look as
though they would be soft to the touch,
each feather is actually made up of sharp barbs
that are capable of piercing clothing and skin.
These barbs release a neurotoxin into the
system that activates every pain receptor
in the body of the victim. The neurotoxin
present in these feathers has not been
identified anywhere else in nature, but is
somewhat similar in structure and function
to the neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue-ringed octopus.
In addition to the pain-inducing neurotoxin, the
feathers also carry several unidentified stimulant
compounds, which seem to be intended to keep
the victim awake for as long as possible. Where
the neurotoxin on its own would induce enough
pain for the affected party to pass out almost
immediately, the stimulants serve
to keep the victim conscious.
SCP Foundation scientists posit that
this is so that 469 can get as much
noise, in this case in the form
of screams, out of its prey
as possible and achieve maximum growth before
the captive creature dies or goes into shock.
Further experiments confirmed this theory, and
showed that SCP 469 will react similarly when
exposed to any living creature capable of making
a sound and experiencing pain, not just humans.
Nonliving matter though, including dead
animals, elicit no response from 469.
Additional experiments were then undertaken
that involved applying various different
sounds in order to test their effect on
SCP 469’s growth. Though it feeds on any
sounds produced in its presence, it seems
to respond most strongly to musical sounds,
exhibiting a particularly strong response
to classical music. No sound elicits
a stronger reaction from this creature,
however, than the sound of ringing bells.
It is rumored that when a bell was
rung in the presence of the 469,
the humanoid at the center of the feathers
is said to have moved for the first time
on record. Apparently whatever is at the center
appeared to “wake up” and unfurl its wings,
revealing itself. But unfortunately, all
security footage of this incident has been wiped,
and the data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature’s true form a mystery.
You may be remembering that four members of
Foundation personnel on record were lost to
SCP-469, and that only two have been mentioned
so far. The second pair of casualties resulted
when the Foundation attempted to terminate SCP
469. Believing that there was no more scientific
benefit to keeping it alive, or at least that
the possible benefits did not outweigh the risks,
it was ordered that SCP-469 be
terminated by any means necessary.
Two skilled personnel, Dr. Jones and Dr. Smith,
were sent into the containment facility in hazmat
gear, armed with several sharp instruments.
They were to attempt to use these to cut through
the forest of feathers and soft bones until
they could reach the humanoid at the center.
It was presumed that once they did
and the creature no longer had the
protection of its poisonous feathers,
that it would be relatively easy to kill.
They could not have been more wrong.
Dr. Jones approached the dense cover of feathers
with a pair of sharpened gardening shears,
while Dr. Smith opted for a machete. At
first, the strategy appeared to be working.
Dr. Jones made several quick cuts, with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to the Hazmat
suit as Dr. Smith slashed into the feathers with
his machete, making similarly promising progress.
However, the situation quickly took a turn for
the worse when Dr. Jones dropped her shears
and let out a bloodcurdling scream. The
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin, but somehow
they had managed to find a way just the same.
Smith grabbed Jones and attempted to make
a break for it, but he was too slow, and
far too close to the feathers already. The wings
wrapped around them and swallowed them both up,
leaving the researchers outside helpless to
do anything but listen to their screams and
wait for them to go quiet. After
several minutes they finally did,
and the now larger SCP-469 had officially
claimed another two Foundation personnel.
Obviously, 469 could not be terminated using any
methods that would place the responsible personnel
within its grasp. That was simply too risky.
So, the Foundation selected a team of D-class
personnel to attempt to burn the feathers with
an array of flamethrowers. Though the feathers
were vulnerable to fire and began to blacken
and disintegrate on contact, the sound of the
flames being expelled was loud enough to feed
SCP 469. Its growth was so quick in response to
the noise that the fire could not keep up with the
amount of new feathers and wings being produced.
By the time the flamethrowers ran
out of propellant, 469 was the same
size as it had been when they started. Other
termination methods have been discussed,
including the possibility of submerging the
entire creature in a highly corrosive acid,
but so far this has not yet been attempted.
Whatever they end up trying, it is clear
that nothing that produces a significant
amount of noise will be able to kill 469.
So, where is it now? What’s become of this
perverse angel with the never-ending wings?
Currently, it is kept isolated in an
airtight, soundproof chamber where
nothing can trigger the growth of any more
wings. So, what is it? An angel? A demon?
A twisted, mutated bird of some kind? It
is entirely possible we will never know.
But It’s a Wonderful Life had
something right, even if by accident.
Every time a bell rings, something, twisted
and deadly though it may be, gets its wings.
Now check out “SCP-096 - Look At A Picture Of
the Shy Guy In Space? The Shy Guy Questions and
Theories” and “SCP-082 - Fernand The Cannibal”
for more Foundation mysteries unraveled!